we have this from the post-millennial
mhm she said hey Trump supporter skip
poll lines at election 2016 and text in
your vote text votes are legit or vote
tomorrow on super Wednesday so texla
votes are uh text votes are legit should
have put her in criminal territory
relative to what this guy did and
there's his too this one just says avoid
the line vote from home text Hillary I'm
with her go Hillary and it's a a meme
it's a joke it's and and the funny thing
is this is 202 when when did when did he
post that that was uh that was 2016
but it was was it after hers uh I don't
know I don't know the she said text
votes are legit right I suppose the
argument is she didn't include a number
to call or did
she because it's a video there there's a
video but the video was taken down which
is why we have that which is why we just
have uh her
screenshot um but yeah so he posted this
the Department of Justice claimed that
it was uh an ad in said and didn't
acknowledge that it was a meme accused
him of conspiracy against rights which
is of course what Donald Trump is being
accused of by the doj right now over
January 6th he was convicted of
essentially election interference and
he's supposed to spend seven months in
prison over this uh we actually got a
message from a fact Checker today being
like can you provide any evidence for
your claim that he was he's being
sentenced to 7 months in prison over a
meme and it's like why yes we can
provide all of the documentation that we
have as well as the Department of
Justice press release about the
conviction in the first place that says
he posted this ad and it was
investigated by the FBI um it's
absolutely insane but it's another first
rights issue uh First Amendment rights
issue and we have had so many of these
recently we see in the cases against
Donald Trump where he's being slapped
with gag orders he's not allowed to
speak publicly about various elements of
the case and it's basically because the
prosecutors don't like getting made fun
of on Truth social that's the issue they
don't like that they feel you know they
feel
insulted when did they actually file
this cuz it was from the 2016 election
oh it was from the 2016 election it's a
meme about it but does it say they
didn't even file a complaint until 2021
so they waited until after 2020 to go
after him like after the whole election
stuff that went on with Trump oh for
something it didn't even affect the 2016
election they pun
hunting people from the old scho Trump
era people that help Trump get elected
the first time they're going after them
even now it's also like out of Pardon
territory like just just in case yep
yeah it was USA Today that reached out
to us but what um let's see when did
they do it they just they just spoke
about the
sentencing uh and they said that uh no
they said um as proven at trial by 2016
Mackey had established an audience on
Twitter with approximately 58,000
followers a February 2016 analysis by
the MIT media lab ranked Mackey as one
of the most significant influencers on
the then upcoming presidential election
uh so they were using that against him
like the fact that he had a platform the
fact that he had a lot of followers his
platform followers follow him because he
makes memes probably because he makes
memes would they be voting for for
Hillary by tax right right yeah it's a
bad argument and we had to explain the
joke to the fact Checker we had to be
like the joke was but these are ENT I
mean these are contemporary political
cartoons that's what's going on here
right so the point is this guy's
followers are not voting for Hillary at
all right right exactly and he need go
to jail and now he's going to go to jail
what they uh they said
um for example on November 1st 2016 in
or around the same time that Mackey was
sending Tweets suggesting the importance
of limiting black turnout so they're
using a racial thing the defendant
tweeted an image depicting an
African-American woman standing in front
of an African-American for Hillary sign
the ad stated avoid the line vote from
home um and they say that that's
deceptive and they're using that racial
thing as though that like somehow makes
it it's kind of like a different
argument from the one that they're
trying to use it's exactly yeah so yeah
H and then they they complain that he
also tweeted the same image in
Spanish but I mean that's actually kind
of funny one they
have yeah you know it's
amusing so um yeah I think what is
happening to timcast over this Fox News
thing that's definitely a 1A thing well
I was thinking and smacky thing if you
just muted the video and had the
transcript it would be like 80% it would
be you could not even get the debate
through that it would be mostly
commentary and jumbled words around I
mean you wouldn't be able to yeah like
it's not the same thing at all yeah the
trans what we said yeah right yeah
definitely cuz we the people who are
like I can't hear what they're saying
I'm like then go watch the debate I
guess yeah yeah we can just go turn on
ABC yourself you know the same but this
this thing with Douglas Mack Macky is a
whole whole another thing I mean it's it
2024 is going to get nuts uh I I I
strongly recommend everybody watch this
morning's culture War if you did not you
need to it was with Dr Robert Epstein
and Robert Bose and we were discussing
uh mostly it was Dr abstein discussing
what what Google does and you got to
watch it two hours of him breaking down
how Google's cheating yep Google's
cheating on the election well so uh it's
really really
simple he said that they have hard Data
Tracking this admissible in court
provable on Election
Day 100% of democrat voters get a
notification go vote really and and
Republic 59% of Republicans get the same
thing that is enough it doesn't matter
uh and I think you I think that may have
been Facebook one of the big tech
companies had done something like this
it doesn't matter if they control what
you what you see or hear all that
matters is they remind you on the day of
Republicans get don't forget to go buy
pizza and wings today don't miss out on
the new uh imagine this it's election
day and you wake up in the morning
you're like am I forgetting something
and you look at your phone and you're a
trump supporter and it says
major discount at Wings you know Wing
store and huge party available get you
know 10cent wings today and you're like
whoa you call your buddies like hey man
they got 10-cent Wings we should go hang
out and you know and watch the game and
like let's let's go and totally
forgetting his election day and the
Democrats wake up and look at their
phone and it says go and vote right now
and they go oh that's right voting today
all takes if they can get 5% of
Republicans not to vote by doing
something like that it's done yeah
that's enough
yep and between that and the Intensive
suppression that there was in 2020 of
anything that would indicate Joe Biden
was a giant liar with a history of
family corruption right you know true
okay so they were putting ads on social
media like reminding Democrats to go out
and vot call ADS what were they like
notification from Facebook itself like
yeah when when when when you go on
Facebook you've never gotten these uh I
yeah I have I have but like it was like
yeah I guess you're right but they were
targeting mostly Democrat what he was
saying is that I don't know if it was
face which platform he mentioned did
this but he said Democrats 100% of the
Democrats in their study got
notifications to go vote and only 59% of
Republicans did interesting yeah that's
all it takes and then there's there's of
course the the the information
manipulation which everyone is mostly
focused on but you got to understand how
simple it is now the interesting thing
is he
said when Ted Cruz filed a letter
basically calling uh I think calling
Google out for this he said we watched
in Georgia the mechanism by which the
bias is created turn
off they're tracking what he said were
eph what they call ephemeral experiences
and this is crazy this is crazy stuff
here's how it works everything you do
online mostly recordable and tracked you
post a tweet someone can archive it
however the Google SE search results
that you get will never be repeated you
get that one time that image that you
see on that page is not stor or archived
anywhere and it's gone in a moment
really yeah yeah I mean it wouldn't be
stored no but yeah I I remember
realizing how crazy it is that my Google
search results for the exact same Search
terms were different than somebody
else's and they'll be different for you
the next time you do it yeah and so with
that why is that why did he say that was
so well that's just the nature by which
Google operates when you search the
algorithm will generate a list of
possibilities and if you search again it
may change
this
is because these things are ephemeral
what happens is
Google I suppose the argument is they
can you can search for Donald Trump
Google can send you the most insane
things ever Trump is Hitler Trump is
evil and you're like oh my oh my God no
one saw that it that it happened you
will never see it again and you can't
prove it so they thought this data is
not being tracked but it's manipulating
people's perspectives perception so what
he started doing what what they do now
is they have a whole bunch of volunteers
tens of thousands I think 12,000 or
whatever and they actually track all the
searches and everything everyone's
seeing and they've actually created a
database proving the bias and track
tracking it in real time so when Ted
crew sent this letter he watched the
lopsidedness of Democrats being given
positive information Republicans being
you know negative information then Ted
crw sends a letter and it's gone and I
think Zack Vorhees a whistleblower who
came out to Veritas uh made a similar
argument think B that's right yeah on
your made a similar similar argument
that Google can turn it off and on and
manipulate elections and all that so
yeah that's it'll be next what happens
they pick what goes at the top and you
can't tell me they don't
because what's really weird too is
uh Douglas Murray's Madness of crowds
has a whole chapter about how when you
type in like married couple it will show
you like
two men and a baby or something weird uh
or or different interracial couples yeah
yeah it's kind of like agenda driven in
the yeah you think you think I haven't
seen a commercial with all white people
in it since the Canadian suicide
commercials like oh and the Army ones
recently are coming out they're white
but there is absolutely an agenda behind
everything because radical leftists run
Silicon Valley they run run the big Tech
Industries they run pretty much
everything that's why it was so
important when Elon musk took over
Twitter it was like one of our guys like
taking over like a giant uh and kind of
leveling the playing field and that's
what we have to do we have to continue
to build we have to continue to start
like a hostile takeover of these tech
companies well or the parallel economy
which I think is so great you know to
see alternative ways like you know um
the company that Tim was just
highlighting at the top the cool Wood
Products don't don't buy them from Ikea
buy them from this you know I think
that's a that's a better way to go
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8:00 pm
and become a member over at timcast.net